greetings it's monday december 21st you
filthy [__] savages
uncle joy's joint is brought to you by
draftkings with down here in [__]
south jersey
making things happen tonight monday
night football
you got yourself [__] the pittsburgh
steelers
giving a ton of wood to the cincinnati
[__] bengals
the over and under is 40 your party
starts [__] tonight you know what i'm
saying
[__] santa you're showing up with a red
suit and a big dick
draftkings is america's top-rated
sportsbook
has rolled out yet another one of their
can't miss
office to celebrate the return of nba
basketball
on [__] wednesday draftking
sportsbook is giving new players
100 to one odds on every
any featured matchup this week did you
[__] hear what i said to you that's
right if all you do is bet one dollar
one freaking [__] dollar on any
featured matchup this week
and if your team wins you cash 100
you're like banging your head off the
wall joey what the [__] are you doing to
me
what am i doing you're going to make a
little [__] bacon that's what you got
to do
take that government money and make it
[__] work for you
there's so many good games coming on
right now and don't forget
the playoffs are right around the corner
so do me a favor
download the top-rated draftking sports
book app
today so you're ready for pittsburgh
against cincinnati tonight
monday night football and then you roll
it right into tuesday with some college
basketball
and then wednesday it's the return of
nba basketball
do me a favor like i said download the
draftkings app
use promo code joey when you sign up to
get
100 to one odds on any featured matchup
this week
that's code joey for new players to get
a shot at
100 on any featured matchup this week
for limited time only on draftking
sports but listen
when it comes to [__] gambling from a
to z draftkings
sportsbook has you covered bacharach
[__] the poker what the [__] fantasy
they've given like 10 people become
millionaires on draftkings
download the app right now use code joey
and here's the part the lawyers make me
say you ready for this you got to be 21
or all the constructors
go get a hat with a propeller on it you
can't [__] begin gambling at a young
age
new jersey pennsylvania colorado
tennessee west virginia
all you [__] gambling states
you're on deposit bonus requires 25
play through restrictions do apply
go to draftkings.com sportsbook for all
the details
now if you got a gambling problem shame
on you
but no big deal there's help call 1-800
gambler or if you're in indiana call
1-809
with it but if you're ready to [__]
party and get your dicks up and your
balls linked by new year's eve
go to draftkings sportsbook app and use
code joey
and get this [__] party started
collect [__]
that's the whole purpose of this
collecting not telling your friend i bet
uh three times with the teaser and no
it's about collecting draftkings
sportsbook
use code joey the joint is also brought
to you by
cbd lion are you [__] kidding me or
what
you're looking for the perfect present
this is it
cbd everybody your grandparents need
listen
you can't see your grandparents right
you gotta go see them touch your hands
through the window like they're in
[__]
covert prison give us some cbd put a
little pep in their step
whether it's the kinesiology tape the
back walls
the dark and milk chocolate the more
kinesiology tape and strips
the gummy bears the tinctures it don't
stop
it don't stop with cbd lion number one
in my [__] world
and you still want to buy [__] cbd or
some [__] momo with a [__] ged
are you [__] nuts or what go to cbd
line right
now read learn learn about terrapins and
how they work how to affect your body
what cbd works for your ailment right
now go to cbdlion.com
preston joey church on the checkout and
get 20 [__] percent delivered to your
house
church or joey work try [__] i don't
know maybe they give you an extra two
points
cbd line is the [__] goods it's
[__] christmas time [__]
let's get this party started i want to
thank draftkings
and cbd lion and you [__] for
watching
let's do this [__] right now hold on i
gotta get this candle lit
candles are lit [__] how you
like me now
hey how you doing
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
greetings what's happening you bad
[__] it's monday
december 21st you got three days of
shoplifting left
and then we're back to [__] uh
sitting around with people they can't
come over your house
they can't do this they gotta wait who
the [__] gives a [__]
it's christmas man be happy i know this
is a tough time of the year for a lot of
people
you know but she's got to be happy this
time of the year i told somebody the
other day i was answering an email and i
told somebody
do me a favor man just smile in the
morning when you're having a rough day
when you wake up in the morning
before you attack your wife or you
attack [__] somebody at work or you
yell at your kid or whatever just smile
sometimes in the shower i just smile
even if i wake up i'm still [__]
coming down off the battery ass like i
did the night before whatever the [__]
i just smile you just after you brush
your teeth
and listerine before you go on the
[__] shower don't even look at
yourself smiling
when you're in the shower just smile
just just give yourself a smile
and watch what happens all of a sudden
your [__] smile will make your memory
think of something that was kind of
pleasant
and you'll fall into it while you
[__] scrub a double-dub and you know
it gets boring in the [__] shower
you're [__] putting conditioning in
your hair you got the [__] loofah
the whole thing by the time you get out
of that shower your perspective will be
so different on the [__] day
i swear to god no matter what i get up
feeling you know sometimes you come
downstairs first and
somebody sends you some stupid email or
something and you
you start the day off with this [__]
punch to the [__] head from
somebody and you go you know what slow
down i'm not gonna let them ruin my
[__] day with that [__] stupidity
and as you're picking out your clothes
as you're putting your socks on your bed
and your shirt
you just smile sometimes i just even
though i have no reason to smile
i think you know because sometimes
things would be worse than what they are
with the conditions that are going on
right now so we since we're holding so
much frustration in from other things in
our lives
we tend to overreact now because you
know it's a lot for people to [__]
handle what's going on right now during
the [__] pandemic
but if you just smile sometimes they
just [__]
smile like that's why when i do the
patreon in the morning
i always try to end up with that smile
for you people because if i smile
you'll smile you won't be laughing at
yeah you're laughing at my stupid
looking [__] face and
my [__] up teeth and [__] but you're
also gonna laugh
you're gonna just smile and go what the
[__] is going on with my life
you know everybody's [__] happy
i'm not happy forced to smile just force
it
not you know like not when you're in a
club drink don't force it don't do an
l.a force
when you're in a [__] club with your
[__] jerk-off buddies
oh my god that's such a funny joke hello
no i'm not talking about that [__] i'm
talking about [__] just by yourself
just
you know you're thinking you're like
frustrated
that [__] bill is due today and you
all said you're like you know what
and you just start smiling and you smile
and you smile
and you keep smiling you're like
remember the time that chick sucked my
dick on under the [__] radiator at
the comedy club
and these memories start coming out and
that's from smiling
so i know this week's gonna be rough
whatever the [__] you think it's gonna
be
start your day off with a smile you
don't need joe diaz or
[__] bill burr or whoever to make you
[__] laugh
if you can't make yourself laugh it's
going to be a rough [__] day
that's it that's all i wanted to say
enough of that that [__]
it's a great week uh we got a [__]
snow storm here
for you [__] who decided to
torture me
and throw grenades at me and say joey is
it time to leave new jersey yet
[__] you i ain't going nowhere yeah you
understand me [__]
listen for you guys who forget let's
just pretend
let's just pretend that my mother took
me out when i was three
that means i did 18 winters here i don't
know if you [__] know that i
did 18
new york city winters slash new jersey
winters
and then i did 12 colorado winters
that's 18 and 12 that's 30 [__]
winters
all right so 27
years is unaccounted for 23 were in
[__] uh
uh los angeles and three were in cuba
and one i don't [__] know what
happened to the one year where the [__]
i was at so maybe i did
31 [__] winters i've done 31 winters
this ain't the [__] first time i've
been cold you people like
what you're gonna come downtime it was
[__] freezing down in texas too it
was 40 degrees they were on stage
rogan had to put jackets on and [__]
like that but you people are like
joey you know like you were teasing me
kind of sort of
when it got snow when you guys don't
understand that
snowing is my life i love it i love it
snowing brings back that and listen i'm
not gonna lie to you
when this as the snow was falling
wednesday night i was like what the [__]
is this
uncle vinnie's got cancelled like a
[__] two
because the governor called the state of
emergency i'm like what the [__]
it's just a little snow i was out there
i picked my daughter up i took her to
kick boxing
i'm trying to hold the hand she's got
her tongue out
trying to catch [__] whatever i just
let her out there
and that's when it started it hit me
like [__] how much fun
is [__] snow i came home
my wife made a pot of [__] meatballs
i called jimmy florentine and his son to
come over
and i go you know what i got to build
the [__] path to them because
i don't want somebody slipping this is
new jersey this is a slip and fall type
of state here
you get suited on a daily basis my
neighbors are like don't sue
don't don't [__] uh shovel your
sidewalks
because like that people [__] walk
their dogs and they'll [__] there
and then they won't pick up the [__] so
[__] that i ain't shoving the snow but
i'll tell you what you gotta shovel that
thing because that's jewish [__]
tendencies right there i see snow on the
sidewalk also i get the
i get the sudden nerves to slip and go
down the [__] urgent can't leave
there with a [__]
jewish [__] gold chain nice little
neck brace for the holidays
just walk around you don't know nothing
but you got to shovel the [__]
sidewalk so what i did was
wednesday night i [__] uh when i
moved here people like dog
you're too old to be shoveling when it
snows just hire a kid
it's [__] eight o'clock at night
seven o'clock at night where am i gonna
get it what do you wanna
knock on people's doors how you doing
man is your kid available to [__]
shovel snow
you know so i just sat here like you
know what i'm gonna have to [__]
shovel that snow anyway so i came
downstairs
i googled shoveling snow over 50. they
told me to put layers on and [__]
because if you need to learn anything
just go on google or youtube
if you go on youtube and go shove in the
snow over 50. don't
[__] them they hook you up jack they
hook you up
so you know they just said bend your
knees don't throw snow
over your shoulders stay out there for a
little while
come back in take breaks whatever
it was [__] tremendous it was coming
down
i went out there i had a little hat on i
had my other sweatshirt on
i put my [__] ipod on i put some
[__] music on
i think i was listening to [__] ufo
one of the ufo not the live one but the
really [__] good one with michael
shannon
and you know what i took a little hits
off the pipe in the garage
nobody knew nothing my wife didn't even
know what was going on and i [__]
went out there
and i just started shoveling and i
didn't know what i was doing i made a
couple [__] ups you know like
i shoved the garage the not the garage
but the
pathway first before i did the stairs
and then i was shoving the stairs to the
bottom
up but after a [__] couple minutes it
just came back to me
i was like holy [__] do i miss this [__]
and i was shoveling at first i tried to
use a broom like i was in colorado one
of my [__] [__]
ain't that type of snow this jersey snow
jack
when this [__] sticks it [__] sticks
so i
cracked open a bag of rock salt my wife
came down
she got the [__] snow blower out and
i did the stairs
the path to the [__] street and she
started on the [__] driveway
and at one point we just made eye
contact and giggled
like it was [__] tremendous and my
daughter's in the window
watching this you know i told to put
your snoop put your [__] snow boots
on and come out
and we just shoveled and it was funny
because you know my daughter was great
she was helping me through
you can't throw rock salt here so we
were throwing that other [__] behind uh
yeah can't you i don't do rock salt on
the brick because you stain it through
the bricks so you gotta
use that other [__] but it was just
great man
you know shoveling at first i was by
myself
and i was getting flashbacks so when i
was a snow shovel
snowmass village 83 joe coffee [__]
great guy
he put an ad out for snow shoveling it
wasn't enough that i had a job as a
[__] and as an
electrician i [__] had a job as a
dishwasher
i was a part-time burglar now position
came up the snow shoveling and he kept
having the sign was there every day and
finally i said
let me go talk to this guy i know joe
what he i lived in d12
he lived like in c12 the building right
next door to me
so i knocked on his door i'm joe coffee
what's going on here
he goes nothing i'm looking for snow
showers do you know anybody what the
[__] am i here
what do you think i'm knocking on your
door here selling avon
when do i start and he goes because it
was open hours you could shovel snow
whatever you want
you could shovel the snow as it's coming
down or you could break the ice up at
night and
you know clean the pathways for people
because it snows all [__] day
and the winter that i moved to colorado
it no 25 [__] days in a row
so i was kind of [__] so i said you
know what let me take my i got this mic
i think let me take an opportunity of
this and get myself make a little money
i was gonna come home
i was robbing and i was [__] i had
some money put away but
you always want to have a cover you
don't want to just be a [__] thief
without a cover
so people saw me out there shoveling
they go this guy's not a bad guy
he's working plus joe coffey was just uh
he's still around joe coffee up in
snowmass village
so if anybody sees him tell him joey
diaz sent him his love
he may be retired i heard a couple years
ago he was still out there doing his
thing
that's a tough ass white [__]
from colorado i love him
but there was another purpose why i
shoveled snow i knew i had two months to
leave to go back to new jersey
and i was casing out the drug deals i
knew all the drug dealers
lived so my responsibility was to shovel
from a building
to like [__] a b c d
[Music]
a b c d
e f g so i my responsibility was c
d e f g i had five buildings
i think there were seven apartments
in each building and it was outside so i
had to start from the third floor
and shove my way down i checked the
little door handles on the way down you
never know you know what i'm saying
i was a [__] mess to society but that
was why i took that job
because i would see when the drug
dealers would go skiing
and i knew they weren't coming back
right away not coming back when you go
skiing you don't come back for a [__]
break
you're already up there already you're
not gonna come back home and if you're
gonna [__] your [__] up on the mountain
they got great little [__] bathrooms
up there so i would just go out there
i would wake up in the morning if it was
too cold to be an electrician or they
slowed up would work
because sometimes they'd make me go wire
a half a house
and then come back home at one i'd go
inside the house warm up for an hour
smoke a joint maybe get a hot chocolate
and i'd go out there and shovel [__]
snow on those days it was rough to rob
the drug dealers
but on the [__] other days when like
i was out there early like if i didn't
have to be an electrician [__] yeah
i was out there at eight in the morning
and that's when people [__]
leave to go skiing they want to catch
the fresh [__] powder
so while they were looking for that
fresh powder i was looking for my own
[__] fresh powder
so i had my roommate at the time see i
lived in c
d e f g but i lived in d12
but all the doors were the same so
they all had the same [__] security
system which is one doorknob
i figured out if i could break in if i
could figure out how to break into my
door
i could break into any other door in the
[__] compound
this is the mind of joey diaz check what
are you guys looking for
christmas [__] recipes i'm dropping
some [__] stories on here today
it's monday morning you can't just leave
here empty-handed
so i figured it out that if i could
break into my own apartment
i could break into any other apartment
from c to h
there probably was about four drug
dealers in those four buildings at the
time
and i was working them like a [__]
savage
i figured out if you took a uh like a
little handsaw
we took a handsaw we welded like we we
cut a piece off so it wouldn't have the
point
so it wouldn't like let the people know
that i was [__] around with that door
always perfect my roommate was a genius
at the time
god rest his soul jimmy i love you with
all my heart
and he devised a tool that would slip
right in i didn't even have to pop the
[__] molding or nothing
he was brilliant so i would just pop it
in he also devised
a move for me to do the back patios
so the patio screen door they were the
easiest they were the best
so whenever i [__] just living there
those those i lived there from
july to february and those poor people
were terrorized
from the whole from the minute i moved
in there july 1st
i was just doing new jersey [__] you
know i was fresh out of jersey
i didn't know what belonged to me what
didn't belong to me
as far as i could concerned it was it
all belonged to me
so from the minute i [__] moved there
you know i was doing little crazy things
nothing too outrageous i didn't really
start going off that year until about
september that's when i realized
this straight live [__] ain't [__]
working going to work every day
i was taking some classes at night that
whole [__] thing
but i just i was just into it i was just
[__] into it
so my buddy had made me this little
[__] tool
and i would i knew the drug dealers were
there was this one drug deal i was a
chef
at a [__] hotel and he would ski
early and what i did was i wouldn't go
into the house and rob them completely
if they had an ounce of coke i would
take like an eight ball
and i would leave the thing there so
they would be confused they'd be walking
around
confused i didn't start hitting them
until like january
that's when i started cleaning them up
but anyway
that whole [__] little slow thing
brought me back to that for a second
until my wife and daughter came out
and they're like dad can we help and i'm
like oh yeah you can help me i'm like
[__] you [__] up my little fantasy and
i've been here the last half hour
because it makes you know it makes the
ski
you don't focus on what you're doing if
you focus on the story while you're
[__] doing something
shitty it makes it a lot easier so i'm
out there shoveling thinking about the
[__] burglaries and whatnot
and those poor people it was a [__]
great time but
it really was it really was i'm not
gonna lie to you i had a great time
those days
i was such a piece of [__] but it was
enjoyable it was not like i was just
kicking down doors i was being creative
i was getting my exercise and
burglarizing some [__] people
and you know what it's like they
suspected me at the end
but i think i told you i played a double
agent i didn't get high in front of
those people
and as far as they were concerned i did
not do coke
i was not interested in doing coke you
know so they were like how can he be
robbing us if he doesn't do coke
what can he be doing with it i was
stocking that [__] up
for my [__] flight to new york city
but my daughter came out with my wife
we did a little bit of [__] uh
shoveling
and then boom florentine came all with
his kid we had dinner again
when they left at like 8 39
i went out there again and shoveled
another
maybe another inch or two had fallen we
got a total of a [__] seven inches of
snow
you know what i do with seven inches i
sprinkle in my [__]
seven inches don't do nothing for uncle
joey i cleaned out my garage now we can
pull the cars into the garage
because that's the worst thing as far as
i'm concerned of the winter
is getting into a cold [__] car in
the morning that
sucks and you're sitting there rubbing
your hands
now i just go in the garage and i open
up the [__] door so i don't commit
suicide
i [__] turned the car oh yeah please
the other day when i had to warm the car
up and i started feeling dizzy
and i'm like oh it's because i didn't
[__] open up the garage door
you guys don't have an idea about the
trials and tribulations of joe diaz and
[__]
i swear to god the first day i went out
there and i started the car up i opened
the windows
i put the heat on like this put pretty
[__] nice in there
i was tired i started feeling a little
[__] up i felt like that guy the
the white guy and the equalizer mr
denzel was gonna kill him by putting
[__] exhaust in this [__] car
and i'm like what am i doing i had to
walk the garage door my wipe them down
she's like how long did you have the
garage door open closed for
like about eight minutes
she goes what made you i don't [__]
know you know me dog i do
bang it i forget what the [__] going
on so
i'm already used to it thank god can you
imagine a [__] wednesday morning
or thursday you guys would have woke up
to usa today
joey diaz can kill himself by mistake in
his garage
because he was too high and he doesn't
open up the [__] garage
all right this is what happened this is
the day of my life [__] what do
you want
you want me to come up here with fabled
stories and you know me [__] winning
three medals you want me to tell you
this [__] that happens to me on a
[__] weekly
this is it this week i almost killed
myself my mistake but
[__] it i'm you what the [__] did i hell
i didn't have a garage in l.a i haven't
pulled the car into a [__] garage
i walk out there it's a beautiful day to
be alive and next thing you know
something may smell it right
did you get over the door to see the day
i swear to god that's my life guys what
i'm gonna do i'm stuck with it i'm no
[__] genius like you guys
you guys got the [__] world by the
balls it was a great weekend
it was a great weekend all together you
know man
when uh thursday morning when i got up
i do something thursday i came back
early morning
and then it warmed up the sun was out
it was a beautiful day and i came in
my daughter and wife were getting ready
to go out thursday to go out and play in
the snow
i think i went upstairs for maybe five
minutes just to pee and wash my hands
and maybe get some water and i heard
just
yelling and screaming and i went out to
the front of my house
and there was three two
eight kids playing
in both of my yards the front building
snowmen
throwing snowballs at each other my
daughter got hit by a snowball i'm like
welcome to new jersey
she's out there crying i'm like welcome
to new jersey hit her in the eye that's
why she was crying
and it just shocked her but i was happy
she got hit with that [__] snowball i
really was i was
ecstatic usually i lose my mind like
what happened i didn't even give a [__]
i know exactly what happened
you got hit with a snowball welcome to
new jersey when it snows
walk around looking like a missile's
coming because we throw snowballs in new
jersey jack we ain't got time
and we'll put a rock in there too and
belch in the [__] head
it don't matter so she got hit in the
head with a snowball
the kid across the street got hit in the
head with his little snowball
and the little girl across the street
had he was about six
got hit in the head with a snowball
listen guys
it's all a part of growing up
it's all a part of growing up when i
went out there on my balcony and i
looked and i saw those kids
it's over i'm officially [__] home
like i didn't know how long it was gonna
take
for me to officially be home be
comfortable
that anxiety has totally disappeared
i mean you could see it on me you could
see it in my face you could see it on my
skin
this has been a [__] great learning
experience
and a great journey i hope you guys are
learning from this also
i called it the mind of joey diaz and
i did all the things i did you you saw
us at our worst
you know uh we had no direction with the
podcast we still don't know what the
[__] we're doing
i'm not gonna just give up just because
i'm gonna give up but
this has been a growth for everybody and
i hope you're all [__] learning from
this i didn't do this
for you guys to learn i mean i'm
learning the pieces along the way
but this is uh this has been a great
[__] journey so far and you know what
made the journey even better
that i made the right decision when i
made the decision
it was time to go i miss la i miss a lot
of my friends i miss
kate i miss you know tom my heart goes
out to him in the hospital
another one of the joint guys in the
hospital big church guy
jay bishop pittsburgh thinking about you
you know brother uh
you know that's it it's official i'm a
[__] official new jerseyan
i threw a snowball i shoveled snow i got
a garage
you know uh it's so [__] weird how
friday night
was the 18th of december usually that's
the saddest night of my [__]
existence
for the last 22 years
that is the saddest night of my
existence
that's the saddest day is that friday
before the christmas
because hollywood would shut down and
when i mean hollywood would shut down
i mean hollywood would shut all the
[__] way down to
you know there's no traffic like there
is now since nobody's working in
california
for a month you had four weeks of no
traffic
people would disappear california
christmases
were not what you guys thought they were
i'm sure there was some families that
were established that had grown up there
that had been there
but nobody knocked on my door and
brought cookies
nobody knocked on my door and brought an
ornament
nobody knocked on my door and said that
they wanted to come over
for christmas eve morning to sing all
these things have happened here
i've had the last three or four days
i've read the doorbell ring
i go to and there's a lady around the
corner with cookies
it's a different [__] experience man
you know it's uh friday night we went to
uh
mercy goes to school with a kid dylan
nice
family i had a [__] blast you know it
was socially distanced we went
downstairs
they had heaters it was ventilated uh
yeah you know
there was air flow we all sat
you know there were maybe like six
parents
and a couple kids and we sat around and
we just shot the [__]
we got to and i'm thinking to myself the
whole time right now if i was in
california
i'd be doing nothing i'd be doing
nothing these guys played games
they played some games with dice that
you had to get the [__] ball
and unwrap it you know you have to
unwrap and there's
gifts along the way and you have to the
kids have to play dice until they get
matching twos
threes you know like two twos two fours
the dice have to match
and then the ball gets passed to the
other kid and i'm sitting there i'm like
right now my daughter would be by
herself in a [__] room
never mind playing with one two
three four five other [__] kids
i was blown the [__] away people were
bringing [__] cakes
they had pizzas they had [__] corn
dogs you know those little [__]
things
i had a great slice of pizza from
[__] dinos
out of staten island and they're in
jersey and new jersey they bring all the
water from staten island
to [__] jersey tremendous this is a
whole different [__] world
it's a whole [__] different world and
then sadly
was the trifecta of [__] life
trifecta it could have been a better
[__] saturday i
listen i live my days i live my weeks
day to day i don't know what the girls
are gonna do
you know she doesn't have school she has
champions
she's got kickboxing you know mike and i
do the podcast two days a week we shoot
videos
on the other day you know it's always
mike has a family
mike has two children they're learning
how to [__] [__] piss
you know he's got a thousand dilemmas
himself you know
he's got to be a dad half the [__]
time
so i don't even know what the [__] i was
getting who the [__] knows
new jersey man new jersey you know you
you don't really [__] know you know
but one thing i was missing
from la that i knew
would switch as soon as i got here is i
would
fall into a click you know i would fall
into a click
so sad you know my clicker so far has
been like joe rail
kid i grew up with eddie connors lives
up the [__] corner from me
my brother bobby who lives in [__]
jackson
you got the [__] florentine family it
was just
the most brilliant family i've ever met
in my life you know
i'm over there two three times a week
watching football with the kids whatever
yelling screaming and saying [__]
[__] i shouldn't be saying
it it's just a lot of fun you know uh
saturday i woke up and i had to go get
my wife
a christmas present
and i knew the only place i i i don't
know what to get my [__] wife
in fact we had to go to the mall
ourselves she sent me to the mall
she goes i know exactly what for you to
get me she goes go to this mall
go to this place they're going out of
business
it's 60 percent off you're gonna love it
i went to the mall i walked in it was
empty guys
but i walked in there and i get [__]
anxiety listen
i'm not a big shopper i don't like
[__] going shopping
if you like i do a video of myself going
shopping at the fat man store you ever
see me at the dxl store
i don't try nothing on i just run the
[__] out of there
so i [__] go down there i
walk into this bright place i'm looking
around at sizes and bras and t-shirts
and [__]
i'm like listen you look at the girl's
tits
you look at that tits and you're like
pick a bra for that [__]
you're not gonna get the right [__]
bra we don't know they got a
b 34 i don't even know 34 b
what's the 34 that's the size of my my
back what's the b it's a b
cup a c cup is the d cup
and he you know what i know about two
cups the two
balls between my legs and that wouldn't
[__] old 58 year old dick that's all
i know
i don't know how to measure [__] d
cups and bras and
you know what no i'm not doing this [__]
i [__] walked out of there i picked
up a couple different christmas presents
and i thought just easy [__] easy [__] i
don't
[__] go in deep i'm not gonna stand
in a deep line
[__] you this is just little knickknacks
i had to send my aunt
my uncle you know [__] i had to get a
frame for my [__] uncle
[__] like that that's it i ran the [__]
out and i came home i told my wife look
i think you're down there
you go in the store i'll stand outside
when the [__]
you pick out whatever the [__] you want
i'll go up i'll pay for it we'll come
home we'll wrap it together we'll make
believe
i got it for your deal done so that
that's my [__] christmas all right i
don't i don't know nothing about
christmas
we ran but you know we both checked out
what we thought we
should give mercy but my wife did all
the [__]
uh handling the whole [__] day i
don't do another
[__] guys i'm terrible with that listen
guys there's some stuff i'm really good
at
christmas [__] i'm [__] horrible at
like i'm horrible at sending christmas
cards
you know i'm going to take a picture of
myself and then print it
happy holidays from uncle joey and
you're going to get about i don't
you don't need my face on your
refrigerator or on your [__]
christmas tree all right
some company reached out joey you should
do like christmas balls
i don't want you to think about me
christmas night all right
yeah like this nice i swear to god
then i do two nut sacks and call them
christmas balls
and people could buy them and put them
on their ornament if you're crazy enough
to put my balls on your ornament i can't
i can't if i was 28 those are my balls
to put on they were beautiful when i was
28.
two heartfelt nuts now it looks like a
[__]
it looks like two nuts with a water
balloon you know you have a water
balloon to have that nipple on the
bottom
that that's just ready to bust yeah the
little [__] thing
i don't even know what that nipple is
for i may have not cancer
it don't matter anymore i don't give a
[__] i'm just happy to be doing this
podcast twice a week
and the patreon i don't give a [__]
comedy i don't know what's gonna happen
with [__] comedy
ain't nobody doing [__] comedy you're
out there just praying
doing comedy now is like i'm gonna go
down and see if i can get coping
that that that's your mindset how to
[__] that's what it's like
dave david powell used to have a great
joke that he would go home at night and
find
and play find the smell find the odor
whatever the [__] one of the funniest
things i've ever heard that's us now
you're just going to [__] we're just
[__] going on the road to see what
comic is gonna die first
that's it that's it that's it we're just
waiting this what comic is gonna die
first and i know the odds are on me and
another couple of the guys go [__]
yourself
i'm not folded into your [__] hands
but sadly i had a great time
sadly i woke up i had to do some stuff
with the girls
the girl said to me listen uh mercy has
to go to kickboxing at 10.
i had a [__] slight window i go [__]
it let me run up north
run the union city pick up a gift from
my wife
and i'll call a few of my buddies he was
around
i was craving a [__] craving a
[__]
sausage peppers empanada from roses deli
up in north berg and a shout out to
rose's deli
[__] tremendous i wanna i've never
been up there before
they make i don't know how many pounds
of fresh mozzarella a day
i went up there a couple weeks ago i had
the the [__] prosciutto
with the mozzarella sandwich i only had
a half of it it was [__] tremendous
it's huge but i can't eat the whole
thing i'll die of a [__] heart attack
so i said let me if i came all the way
up here
i would went i went by my [__] uh
i went by my [__] the jewelry store i
got what i needed from my wife then
i said [__] it i'm gonna go home and on
the way down the hill
i stopped at the [__] cemetery i
didn't have [__] snow boots though
they must have got a foot of snow up in
north bergen they've shoveled
that i could go all the way down to the
[__] cemetery
so i drove all the way down to the row
she's at
there was like an inch on each [__]
tombstone i walked around for like five
[__] minutes i'm like [__] this
merry christmas [__] and i got back in
my car
i love your mom but you know i'm not
walking around out here like i'm
trekking up in alaska
this ain't no reality show for national
[__] geographic
those dudes with snowshoes on this [__]
looking for a grave
i'll catch you next week have a [__]
great christmas
you've been there for 40 years you ain't
going nowhere no i had to go i had to go
throw a little blessing on my mom for
christmas
and then i said [__] i got a little
[__] time left let me shoot up the
roses and get a couple of empanadas
i'll see you totally avenues open so i
shot up dungley avenue
i went up to roses thank god there was a
[__] parking spot
i went [__] in there i got a couple
[__] empanadas
then my phone rang it was a buddy of
mine chirpy
one of my best [__] friends in life
he's like hey man
i got something for you i go [__] it you
know what i got something for you i
brought a couple edibles up there for
some of my friends
just you know just in case you know
whatever the [__] they're thinking
not for me i brought him up from him i
didn't have weed in the car
i just brought up i go you know what
chirpy has been my friend
since 1979. there's not too many people
i
trust in the world like i trust chirpy
he's just uh
you know i'm like i'm gonna tell you the
people's nicknames i saw yesterday
just so nobody gets [__] confused i
saw chirpy
and we sat in the car you know
for maybe 10 minutes then we got out we
[__] for another 10 minutes
and i looked at him and i'm like i can't
believe i know you for
close to 42 [__] years 43 years this
is just
amazing chirpy's chirpy you know
he lives at home with his mom uh
he's a hustler he's waiting on
unemployment he got it
he's in between jobs he's my age but
he's a genius
and he was there for me when there was
nothing he was there for me when people
wanted to [__] shoot me
so i sat with him we bullshitted i
gave him a little bit of [__] i gave
him a container edibles he was
he hit me back last night nice and
smooth and he
put a picture of his mother's chicken
parmesan sandwich
he goes i'm in [__] heaven thank you
for the edibles
from there i called another buddy of
mine i'm in the neighborhood you're
around and goes i'm
around because i just slipped at the
park walking the dog let me drop the dog
at home
you want to get a bite to eat i [__]
said absolutely
i shot up there i met him we sat
at a [__] nice restaurant we were
alone in the back just me and him
and we had a nice light lunch had a nice
little
bowl of lentil soup and a nice seafood
salad you know nothing fried
no bread no nothing i drank water
i sat with him for maybe an hour i got
up
i gave him a hug i got in my [__] car
and i shot and went to see georgie at
his fairview shop
i brought him a few of the empanadas for
lunch i knew he had his hands filled
so i brought him a few of the empanadas
i think i had a [__]
uh an iced tea in the car and i gave him
another some edibles i had
and he was working he was high up in it
and you know i said listen i'm gonna let
you go because i know you're busy you
got front customers coming
i got my [__] car and i came home but
i tell you when i was driving down
bergen boulevard down kennedy boulevard
yesterday
or saturday i'm sorry it just hit me
that i just spent the day with three
of the most important people in my
[__] life
like some people don't get to ever do
that i
i mean and you know we all have friends
do you remember
when i did the this is not happening and
i made a statement
that you know the show friends ruined it
for everybody
because it made people think that they
had to have all these dinner parties and
20 people over i have so many friends
i'm loved
you're not loved you got a bunch of
[__] jerkoffs standing around you
you know those three dudes that i saw
yesterday
whether it was for ten minutes or four
was for an hour
i i gotta tell you something if it
wasn't for them
i wouldn't be here that's listen i can
tell you whatever story
i want to tell you and you can believe
whatever you want to believe
but if it wasn't for those three guys
and the combination that they came into
my life
first of all all those three
relationships over 40 [__] years
you don't judge a man by his [__]
cars
or by the little woman he drives by the
woman the woman he drives
by the car he drives or the woman the
[__]
trophy piece he has on his arm or
whatnot
i'm looking to see if it's snowing out
there it's snowing
uh you you judge a man by his friends
i'm telling you for me i've i've always
been
i've been poor i i'm a [__] felon
i've always had so many things not going
for me i almost killed myself in the
garage
i can't change a flat tire i can't fix a
car
i'm not good with a lot of [__] i'm not
good at things
but one thing i was always good at was
being a friend
like a [__] friend and to think
that at this point in my life at this
age
that i still have those three guys in my
life
who pretty basically formed me as a man
like
jim uh chirpy never let me down
you know those people you call a dog i
could call him
i called him many a time with many
dilemma with other people that told me
to go [__] myself
other people would have told me to go
[__] myself he checked me a couple times
but he always took care of me and i
never [__] forgot him because of that
there's people in north bergen that's
decided not to talk to cherokee because
of different things
you know we were kids we got in trouble
together and listen
if that's what you want to do if you
want to turn your back on somebody you
know for 40 years
we can't be [__] friends no more i
wouldn't be dick
if it wasn't for this guy because he
showed me something special friendship
when nobody was my friend you know he
was there for me he would bring me food
and money and you know when i was at the
park i needed a sweatshirt he brought it
to me when i was homeless
little things that he could have told
everybody he didn't how much of a
deadbeat i really was
but he kept it to himself and he
believed in me
and the guy james the doctor who i had
the lunch with yesterday
i've known him since i was 14 years old
i don't know how many times he visited
me on colorado
all those years i don't know how much
time i don't know how many times
he sent me the emergency 200 on the road
because i bumped into a problem or
something i can't tell you all the times
he was there for me
times i stayed at his house i know his
mom his dad his sister
his wife you know it's just meant it's a
40-year friendship
and george jesus christ i go with george
says when my mother was alive i go with
all these guys
all three of them i knew since my mother
was alive so
i i i saw george for two minutes three
minutes we giggled about something
you know these are three guys that
i i don't even know what the [__] to say
i mean
how lucky am i but all i remember
saying in that this is not happening is
that
who needs a hundred friends with with
three people
i could take over the [__] world and
with those three guys
next to me i could take a little [__]
world if i wanted to
i just don't really want to have the
time i'm too old i got a [__] dog i
got [__] to do people to see
but that whole drive home
it's a 50-minute drive home it was a
50-minute drive home that
it pushed me to tears at different times
of the ride
because i cannot believe that i am so
fortunate to still have these guys in my
life
and that they know how important they
are to me in my life and trust me
i got more i got timmy i got devo
i i you know i'm one of the luckiest
[__] guys in the world
you know and when it comes to that
because i always knew
you could have all the money in the
world but if you ain't got a
[__] to watch your back
what good are you when you have money
people hang out with you
yeah when you have money coke people
hang out with you it's the [__]
that hang out with you when you ain't
got dick
and before your dick these guys knew me
before
they knew me when every time they saw me
they got a complaint about me
and they still stuck it out with me so
how [__] special do i [__] feel
now
that now i could turn around and i could
be
i'm their friend with no [__] drama
at all i also saw my nephew yesterday
nikki ascalis i love this [__] i
saw him at
roses you know i mean it was just a
great day i saw my friend kathy moran's
wife
on county boulevard it was just a great
day and guess what
at the end i turn around i get back on
route 3 the turnpike
and i shoot down and i'm [__] home
but guess what i'm home no matter where
i
am in new jersey i'm i had a [__]
phenomenal time
saturday up in north bergen it which is
phenomenal and what did i do
did i get high no but i do blow no did i
get my dick sucked no
i just spent it with old friends and it
felt
so much better on the 19th of december
you know what i would be doing on the
19th of december in l.a nothing
waiting to do my 9 15 spot the comedy
store
here all day i'm not waiting to do a
spot no more at night
i'm just spending time with my [__]
family and my friends
and just being normal and just getting
well in the head the change you guys are
saying
it's just the unwinding yeah i'm
i'm still gonna do the podcast i'm
having a great time with the patreon
you guys got your [__] shirts cool
[__] shirts
i gotta hand it to you i got sick and
tired of looking at the [__] jesus
machine gun myself it was time for a new
[__] you know i'm saying trust me
joey what the [__] you don't need to
tell me i put that shirt on with g
but to share with jesus with the machine
gun meant something
and that's what people like my friend
said to me somebody on patreon said to
me
i can't wear that shirt on my
grandfather
because he's a [__] pastor [__] him
he should know
jesus ain't gonna come back with 12
[__] idiots this time
and say hello and throw blessings on you
he's coming back with a machine gun
it's a different [__] world out there
you know what i'm saying you don't think
he's gonna get a choke hold from a
[__] cop
[__] no jesus is coming back
stronger than ever [__] so
patreon
i hope you got your shirts i hope you
enjoyed them you know
i had words there that describe who the
[__] i am you know
addictions these are the mind of joey
diaz i love doing all this [__]
i love doing the patreon i love coming
here and doing the podcast for you
on a [__] monday and [__]
wednesday sorry about that
my dick popped out there for a second
hannah i had to get everything [__]
organized there
let me just see where we're at here
yeah no the [__] the shirts came in
a little one just a little one the peppa
in the room you know what i'm saying
every once in a while
you gotta let out these beat those
mallows these are no
no stink farts you know i'm saying he's
like no flower cookies you know
all that [__] now there's always missing
ingredients
no baking cookies no whatever this has
no
juice to it this is no more i'm doing
the garlic but i changed brands the
other brand was making me it was making
me lose friends
this is just a little explosion between
the legs and you move on ten minutes
later nobody gets their feelings hurt
so that's it and that's that what the
[__] do you want to talk about
my [__] saturday was complete man i
got to see those guys
i came back we went and got my dope my
wife her christmas presents
thank god i got that out of the way
uh we got some [__] to eat on the
[__]
uh you know nothing fancy last night
and then we came home and my night was
really [__] made
because i went to check there was a ufc
fight on saturday night
and i went to check i didn't even i
didn't even watch the fight that's how
that's that's how so far off i am that
was the last
uh card for the year also which is
[__] crazy that they're not having a
december 29th card
but that's just to let you know where
we're at i think they've completed all
the fox cards on the ufc
and uh but we lost to ufc for the rest
of the year till
january whatever there's a fight then i
know we got khabib and dustin poirier
but i came home last night you know
answered some emails on patreon [__]
around
and uh went upstairs out there was a
movie frozen was on something for my
daughter
but i went and i checked to see if the
honeymoons were on at 9 30
and there was the christmas episode
that's one of the best episodes ever
because at the end they break out of
character
they break out of character in 1951
and they call out ed norton and audrey
meadows
the tour and they [__] do uh you know
they wish the audience a merry christmas
the place goes
[__] ape [__] so i was like i'm not
[__] missing this
so i came down [__] stairs i got my
head together i got tuned up
i went upstairs i told mercy mercy do
you want to keep watching frozen
or do you want to watch the honeymoon
she's like i want to watch the
honeymooners
so i broke out a bag of wise onion and
garlic potato chips that's what you're
probably
that's what that fart was an onion and
garlic potato chips it was just a
regular bag
not the big big [__] gabon bag and i
broke it up into three little piles
plus three and we watched the money
movies like a family
we giggled and at the end of the episode
i [__] cried
because that was always my favorite
episode you know
i i love the [__] the the carlos and
the [__]
and the callers teaching to the mambo
and when he finds the suitcase filled
with money
i love all those episodes but the best
one
to show jackie gleason's [__] heart
is that christmas one
it's [__] brilliant and
just the fact that i got to watch it
with my [__] daughter
just the fact that you know
i've been thinking about my other
daughter a lot lately jacqueline
and yeah i [__] up
nothing i could do about it she's 30
[__] years old now
you know it came and went uh
there's hope for our relationship but i
know that there isn't really the damages
done
you know put away the whip the ponies
dead type deal
but it's so weird i'm sitting there with
mercy last night watching the
honeymooners
and i'm getting to do everything i
wanted to do with jackie growing up
you know it's saturday night i should be
in some show
entertaining some theater and laughing
and smoking pot and having a good time
but i gotta be honest with you i'm
having a better time sitting there with
my daughter
watching the honeymooners on a [__]
saturday night with my daughter and my
wife
the [__] honeymooners ends at 10 my
wife looks at me at 10 15 and says she's
going to bed
and i sit around until 11 30 12 by
myself writing listening to music
getting this ready getting that ready
looking through my albums
getting ready for the whole new week
coming up but it's just so weird
that i got such a great [__] second
chance
you know and i'm so [__] grateful and
that never leaves my mind any [__]
day
you know i got a chance to come home
just
come back i got a chance that it was a
great week
the snowstorm you know i finally pulled
the cars into a garage with
which made it even feel more like
[__] home
and then i got to see the three people
in my life you know and like i said
i'm gonna see some more friends this
week hopefully i'll get to see timmy
he's a big part of my [__] life
hopefully i'll get a chance to see the
gear and
uh devo and uh
to really make my you know today i'm
gonna see my other brother
bobby uh i'll see joe real you know i'm
definitely gonna see
the [__] florentine crime
family my favorite people in the [__]
world you know
it's so weird i was explaining to him
last week
that like in january or february
i got approached to do this really
odd job i i had to sign
paperwork you know to i had to sign a
an adr or whatever the [__] they call it
so i wouldn't tell what the show was
about but the network is working on a
show
um yeah i could talk about the
the i could talk around the show
but i'm going to show you the lesson
that i learned from not doing this
i gotta i got reached out to me
whatever like somebody from the outside
said hey these guys want to talk to your
dear friend of mine
he said they have an idea they sold it
they got picked up by a network
they're going to get picked up for 13
episodes and they're really interesting
you in being one of the co-hosts or
whatever
like okay what's the show about and they
said the guy's going to call you
and he called me there's a show right up
my [__] alley
right up my alley and it was a show
about the witness relocation plan
and the people who have gone into it and
how they've changed lives and blah blah
blah
blah blah blah they had a 13 episode
commitment
and [__]
it was luke it was luke it was real loot
uh the pandemic hadn't started yet
so i was still you know doing okay with
the stand-up
um i was like hey that sounds
interesting you take me off the road for
a couple months
you know and it was uh then i met with
the guys
i had like a conference call with them
and they were okay and then we met for
like a little bit of a dinner
and they really broke it down to me to
what i would be doing
and it was
interviewing guys that have been into
the witness relocation plan
and what they have done and how good it
was for them
and just all this [__] you know
but out of the 13 episodes i it was one
like pilot episode
and there was 12 guys that were
basically all of them were italian
mobsters you know for example there was
a guy in houston texas
who was from jersey and he opened up a
strip club down there
i don't think he's still down there they
were just the isolated guys you know but
it was basically
organized italian mafia guys
you know uh
yeah i was all in i was all in
uh in fact they had one of the
witnesses call me he got he was a lot
older now
um i always thought the guy that
they made called me you know from
reading his books
and whatever and it's not samuel gavin
by the way i hope you enjoyed that
[__] pilot
episode of sammy the bull uh gravanos
pilot i told you his podcast is going to
be fire
he's a great storyteller he's got great
stories
and he lived them this isn't somebody's
son
or somebody's sidekick anyway enjoy sami
the bulls podcast i don't know what the
name of it is
look it up it's definitely on youtube
[__] sirens
fbi reports great [__] podcast
uh i don't know dick about dick i in
fact i get a call
the producer asked me do you want to
talk to this guy because he's gonna
it was his idea he sold it he's in the
witness relocation plan
he's the next gambino guy and
uh he's older as soon as i got on the
phone with him after three minutes
i read his book 20 years ago you know
when i moved to l.a i knew i was gonna
get cast
to do all those roles so i read as many
mafia books as i could
just so i could always have characters
in my head to work with
it's a stupid thing but whatever it
worked 20 years ago
people change so i [__] uh
talked to the guy and after five minutes
i knew from reading his books that this
guy was filled with [__]
kind of sort of but now from talking to
him on the phone
he was uh full of [__]
he was the next gambino he was like the
next gambino associate
i mean all these guys are basically like
low-level guys
but they blow themselves up to be bigger
level guys
sammy the bull was saying the ball that
[__] was an underboss
that's a big different [__] story i'm
talking about like
louis fingernails from the lucchese
family in new jersey and all the
it was just like [__] and i ended up
talking to
the guy from the gambinos and i think i
talked to an old banana guy
you know on the phone so they were gonna
fly him
we were gonna shoot in san diego and you
know
the money was good i told him i i was
interested
and then one night it was like what i
tell you guys happens i go to bed early
something is on my mind i wake up at
three in the [__] morning
and i i
you know have insomnia as i'm pissing if
i'm pissed about something something's
bothering me if i wake up in the middle
of nights because something's bothering
me
so i [__] uh
you know sit down and get the notebook
out and also the hand starts going in
the journal
and it's basically i don't want to do
this job
like i'm like i don't want to do this
job i don't care how much they're going
to pay me per episode
you know i don't care if the [__]
show blows up and i mess up
i don't want to do this i don't want to
glamorize something
that i don't [__] believe in that's
number one i don't want to glamorize
ratting
and number two is like how can i give
these guys a spotlight
do you know how much [__] like the
three dudes i met yesterday
all three of them are [__] idolized
like all three of them are [__]
italians
you know george is like mixed he's like
a [__] mutt he's like i have breed
but
he starts italian the other two guys are
full
you know strength proud hard-working
blue-collar italians and i thought to
myself
[__] when i die when my mother died
italians took me in
when you know i was growing up italians
took me in italians took me in italians
took me in
you know what man i don't need the money
that much to [__]
i mean we all need a lot of [__]
money
but i don't need the money that bad to
betray
the people that helped me growing up so
i said [__] it
i'm not gonna take this job i called the
guy and i gave the guy some excuse
because they were gonna shoot
uh like the first week of february
they're gonna shoot the pilot
i called the guy i gave him some excuse
about
something but deep down inside i didn't
want to do it because
i didn't want all the kids that helped
me become who i am today especially the
italian ones my friends
i didn't want them to look at me in a
weird [__]
way after that i mean it'd still be my
friends but
i did something over money that they
gave me over friendship
so i turned the [__] job down i said
i don't want the job the pandemic came
i never said nothing to nobody when they
decide to close the [__] schools
i called one person jimmy florentine
because i knew his sister
was a realtor my sister-in-law trish
was a realtor and i knew he could help
me out
and guess what they did help me out and
guess what
they're my new family here in jersey so
sometimes
you gotta [__] take a pass on
something
to make something better and now we're
probably gonna spend one of the nights
for christmas with them
they have two family then my family i
don't know why i'm telling you this
story i'm telling you the story because
i want to tell you that every [__]
move has a consequence
and the universe never [__] forgets
if i would have sold out my [__]
italian
brothers and sisters for a [__]
paycheck i wouldn't be in this house
right now
and i wouldn't be who i am or where i am
today because
i turned my back on somebody so i'm
happy today
that i haven't i didn't take that
[__] job
over [__] money it's not and i left
l.a
i left money on the table in l.a because
i wanted to come back here and have
what i just described to you was family
friends the holidays snow
and just being [__] happy i hope you
guys enjoyed the podcast today from the
bottom of my heart
i know it's monday the 21st a lot of you
people
are having a hard time [__] all that
[__]
next year's our year i promise you this
year was supposed to be the year the
savage
ah things fell apart some chinese people
lit a firecracker
and some of us got [__] up what are
you gonna [__] do who are you gonna
blame
you got nobody to blame we're gonna make
it through next year
and next year will be a better year and
by then we'll figure out what we're
going to do with this [__] podcast
how we get guests i looked at an office
this week
i just went and looked big but it's in a
building i can't have that i want an
office
that has a daughter outside so people
aren't worried about covered when we get
them as guests
and whatnot anything uh vinnie's
wednesday night
the 23rd that i'm not going to do
anything if i do something next week
i'll let you guys know on wednesday's
podcast i might do something at one of
the other clubs in jersey next week
just to get shot outside of christmas
just to see some people be limited
capacity i was really thinking of doing
a new year's
pay-per-view with jimmy florentine
and uh rich voss we're gonna just
find the bar and do it but you know what
man
you can't be out past 10 you can't have
more than 25 [__] people
you know for you guys to feel a
pay-per-view in the house
you got to feel the energy in the
[__] room
ah i'll let you guys have a nice new
year what i am going to do for new
year's is
at some point of the night do some type
of live stream for patreon
check in with you guys smoke a joint
where you maybe drink a glass of
champagne which
may be an edible or something like that
is that good
what do you think if that'll work
that'll work
i love you [__] thank you very
much for listening
thank you for having my back and now for
a word from our sponsors
all right i want to thank you guys for
paying attention today
you know me doug i do a couple bowls in
the morning i don't know what the [__]
i'm talking about
but i tell you what i do know what i'm
talking about
money when it comes to [__] gambling
i got draft kings for you from the
[__] heart
of [__] jersey where draftkings
[__]
has roots [__] this is what i'm
talking about
now that i moved to jersey representing
draftkings
like a [__] savage and it starts
tonight monday night football
pittsburgh against cleveland or is it
cleveland
cincinnati that's what it is i'm sorry i
get confused all these [__] cities
it don't matter i don't care what city
what country
when you're on draftkings tonight with
monday night football we're gonna make a
little money it's over and under it's
40.
you got a nice parlay coming at you you
got a high [__] line but who gives a
[__]
let me explain some to you draftkings is
america's top rated sports book
and they've done it again you like joy
what they do now they did it again
to celebrate the return of nba
basketball wednesday night
draftking sportsbook is giving new
players
100 to one odds on any featured match-up
this week
what are you talking about joey what am
i talking about [__]
you bet a dollar and if your [__]
thing wins
you get a hundred [__] dollars
you bet one dollar one [__] dollar on
any featured matchup this week
and if your team wins you get a hundred
dollars take that government [__]
money you've been waiting on those
you've been waiting on unemployment
hello my name is jo
yeah [__] all that [__] take that buck
of money and let's make some more money
there's so many games out right now i
don't even know what the [__] to tell
you
between nba basketball college
basketball
football playoffs are around the corner
head to the app today
to check out the daily odd boost plus
the [__] fantasy
plus the poker whatever the [__] you
want that ad
if you haven't signed up yet today is
that [__] day
you're sitting there moping around like
a [__] moulin rouge
you might as well make a [__] some
action tonight
download the app now it's safe secure
it's reliable
most importantly it's your [__] money
deposit and withdrawal you can meet at
your
convenience download the top-rated
draftkings sports book app
today right now use promo code joy when
you sign up
to get 100 to 1 odds on any featured
matchup this week
that's code jury for new players to get
a shot at 100
on any featured matchup this week for a
limited time only
at draftkings sportsbook listen this is
the week
these next two weeks this is the [__]
week right here
if you play it smart you can make a
little money all right you got monday
night football tonight you don't want to
do it partly you do the [__] total
then you swing into tuesday night listen
don't
get the espn game get one of those games
that nobody's watching you know what i'm
saying
new mexico state against [__] i don't
know
i don't know some other [__] set of
moocs or something like that nobody's
watching that game
that's the weaknesses that's where your
hole is and wednesday night
you roll into nba basketball with
draftkings and one of these matchups
you get a hundred dollars [__]
wednesday maybe thursday you're rocking
all [__] weekends
i know there's nfl football come on go
to draftkings right now download the app
and use code joey now here's the [__]
part the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 a holder if you're
under 21 go play with your dick
somewhere go play in traffic get the
[__] out of here
new jersey indiana pennsylvania colorado
tennessee
only you know wherever your [__]
sports booking we're ready for your
draftkings
deposit bonus requires 25 times play
through
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
slash sports book for details now if you
got a gambling problem
i don't want you lurking around i don't
want you [__] selling your tv
and blowing some [__] in indigent
just so you can put a bed in that's not
gonna work if you got a problem
call one eight hundred gambler and if
you're in indiana for one eight hundred
not with it okay but if you don't have a
gambling problem
[__] that [__] i got nine nine problems
and a [__] ain't one
download the draftking sports book app
use code joey
and cash in on this tremendous deal have
a great week
the joint is also brought to you by i'm
like vanna white
cbd lion [__] tremendous you
understand me
anxiety pain aches listen it's not a
cure-all it helps
it's great for your body improves
circulation but you don't know that
you're sitting there going everybody's
talking about cbd let me do something
about it do something about it
go to cbdlion.com right now read
learn about cbd cbn
look at the third party lab results and
see what we're working with here
my knee starts to hurt i pop a couple
gummies i'm all right i'm walking around
listen i'm not [__] uh you know
ronaldo nehemiah jumping over [__]
hurdles
but it helps the kinesiology tape is
tremendous you had a rough day
at the gym jiu jitsu whatever jumping up
and down
the bad [__] balls listen cbd has to
be covered i don't want to hear none of
your [__] excuses
go to cbdlion.com right now and preston
joey
or church i'm giving you two [__]
options whatever you feel like spelling
that day
you get twenty percent off delivered
right to your [__] crib all right
who do you think you're [__] dealing
with joey bananas i'm gonna get you
healthy
and i'm gonna put a little money in your
pocket with draftkings i want to thank
draftkings
i want to thank cbd live but most
importantly i want to thank you [__]
savages
for paying attention and having my
[__] ear let me give you an ear
beating twice a week i love you
[__]
patreon you got your shirts i love it
it's going to be a great week merry
christmas
and we'll talk about new year's next
week who gives a [__] you might get shot
in the head this week
stay black love you guys
you